numéro 10 c'est mon poto que j'adore
paga
gagnerait alors c'est ce qui a été
révélé voilà ces salaires ont été
révélés en fait que relayer nous on
n'est pas là entre trente et cinquante
mille euros par mois voilà placement de
produit et tournage donc trente et
cinquante mille euros pour pas gâté
numéro 10 en numéro 9 c'est milla jasmin
entre 30 et 70 mille euros par mois
tournage placement de produit sa marque
de jasmin de parfums et de passât
santana
jared léana zaoui de 10000 à 100000
euros par mois
tournage publicité compte en les femmes
en septième position c'est astrid mercia
entre 20 et 100 mille euros par mois
tournage placement de produits compte
mime et on les fans d'alain contenu
ouais voilà c'est comment une ouverture
voilà sa démarche de c'est exactement un
truc ou si tu veux voir des photos un
peu plus est les idées voilà tu tues tu
paye en plus c'est ça vous devriez le
faire
c'est que daniel sur son compte en
banque ni faillir ça va ça va faire mal
en sixième position car la moreau et
kevin guedj 200 milles à 120000 euros
tournage parce qu'on produit salon
esthétique mon caprice 2.0 leur marque
également pull serra son site et on va
rentrer maintenant dans le top 5 il ya
jazz et laurent korcia 120000 à 200000
euros par mois 5 300 par mois passera
par fars siècle alors et jolie entre 120
mines et 200000 euros par mois tournage
placement de produit paris sportifs
émission j lc famille ni sur tf6 en
quatrième position c'est manon et julien
tanti 230 milles à 200000 euros par mois
tournage placement de produit salon
esthétique bocci evans et le remarque
est une boutique est une boutique en
ligne on va rentrer dans le top 3 donc
des plus gros salaires de téléralité en
numéro 3 c'est celle que j'adore je les
adore maeva guéna
250000 euros à 200 mille euros tournage
placement de produit sa marque de
cosmétiques maeva guen à mme viotti mais
il va là que je fais un bisou voilà qui
gagnent entre 150000 à 200000 euros par
mois elle est 3e d inflation en numéro 2
j'aime aussi beaucoup
c'est jessica qui venant et thibaut
garcia 300000 euros par mois tourner à
ce placement produit leur marque djilor
bien nochi et b brillance et enfin vous
vous en doutez bien la queen la numéro -
la reine
c'est bien sûr nabila on embrasse fort
au sima nabila d'amour 350000 euros par
mois tournage passeriez animations
collaboration avec myriam qu'à sa marque
de cosmétiques nabila la boutique voilà
donc ce sont donc les ses salaires qui
ont été donc révélée est ce que ça vous
choque vous ces salaires ou est ce que
vous dites moi ça me choque pas parce
que voilà c'est normal mathieu tout ça
me choque pas non ça me choque pas
lucion que j'étais à saint tropez un ou
deux ans et j'étais en train de donner
la ville et le coeur brisé dans l'hôtel
dont j'avais été les voir et tous à
discuter un peu avec et je reconnais sur
le parking avec eux des mercedes classe
g mg 63 à tous des voitures à 250000
euros il en parle de manière très très
décomplexée et pardon de le dire mais il
ya eu je sais pas combien peut-être 6000
7000 8000 candidats de télé réalité
depuis que ça existe bon c'est un top 10
ils sont ils se débrouillent très bien
je ferai pareil à leur âge si je pouvais
c'est un vrai métier mais quand je dis
c'est vrai métier il passe des heures et
des heures et des heures pour un truc
dernier propose tc 4h 5h même le petit
benoît que je connais de benoît dubois
que tes posts quelque chose ces quatre
heures 4 heures 30 c'est un vrai métier
j'ai juste envie de dire bravo bravo
quoi enfin bravo 2-2 a parfois eu un
petit peu vulgaire avec c'est ce qui
peut choquer mais en même temps ils ont
20 ans j'aurais fait pareil à 20 ans
j'aurais acheté des grosses bagnoles et
démontrer tout ça mais plutôt bravo
alors vous vous êtes choqués oui moi ça
me choque parce que ces sommes là elles
sont énormes et si elles étaient
déclarés en france parce que je le
rappelle la majorité des dîners profil
qu'on voit ici sont expatriés
fiscalement
les vôtres en argent mon propos on met
par exemple à l'effort collectif
participe à l'effort collectif c'est à
dire avant de partir et quand ils
reviendront pas ce qu'ils vont revenir
et qui vont se retrouver à l'hôpital eh
ben ils vont être bien être content de
la billie jean sera d'ailleurs bon et
ben voila et ben moi ça ça me choque du
coup parce que ces sommes là qu'ils
soient énormes devrait participer à
l'effort collectif français notamment
ces poussières jradi non moi en fait ça
me choque pas parce qu'à partir du
moment où il va là ils gagnent l'état
requérant lordan ouais ça je trouve que
d'un point de vue moral c'est quand même
très très contestable et moi ça me
choque mais moi je n'y crois pas à ces
montants fait assez
vraiment jeté l'épongé alors on a mis la
main pour agir avant
je peux te le dire oui c'est sûr ma
devise et même si alors celle là alors
non je voulais du moins croître andré
julien avait dû venir à toi je vais te
dire un truc à haskell du rallye et je
connais bien le dossier giuly ça ce sont
les salaires qui ont été pris vraiment
au mc saïda baissé mais voilà là tous
les salaires sinon même s'abaisser mais
je ne raconte pas ça aujourd'hui c'est
passager a baissé de 30 % en un mois
c'est énorme toujours mais la réponse a
baissé de 36 ans jean 10% à 2 350 non
mais oui mais oui zucca bien sûr
d'années de données pour moi c'est un
système un peu opaque et un peu
d'esbroufé on sait pas trop où on sait
pas comment ça marche on sait pas des
agents on comprend pas pourquoi alors
les qui a dit rossi sans facture on le
fera t on mais c'est énorme et c'est en
s'activant pour moi tout ça est
complètement opaque et c'est un truc qui
va tomber à un moment donné ça va être
catastrophique et bien leur vendront
leurs sacs à main qui coûtent des
milliers d'euros elles ont des dizaines
qui 31 mai
mathieu mathieu oui pardon pour
peut-être sa musique cependant dépenses
elles n'ont volé à personne c'est pas de
l'argent c'est parce qu'enfin elle
pourra pas en acheter autant si c'était
en france et qu'elles devaient payer 20
points et puis je
salue à jour uniquement facile de donner
des leçons quand on maintenant je ne
donne pas elle que si demain tu gagnes
400000 euros par mois je ne donnais pas
te propose d'aller à dubaï qui se faire
payer d'impôts peut-être que tu
hésiterait on est on est prenant moi je
ne joue pas sinon moi je serai fier de
payer des impôts en france mais c'est ce
qu'on dit quand on également non non non
écoute quand même en garde ciry le noble
âge il a pas mal de la paix mais je dis
ça par rapport à géraldine qui qui pense
que potentiellement c'est pas c'est pas
vrai que yahoo ces sommes là il suffit
de voir ce qu'elle possède en termes de
matériel c'est énormissime elles
dépensent des millions dans l'est des
vêtements des voyages
je
viens d'aller rival m j'entends ce
j'entends ce que tu dis tu te perds sur
un plan moral en dix ans elles ont trop
de trop de sacs à main entre de machin
c'est pas à nous de juger si elles ont
trop de sacs à main ou s'ils sont trop
de voitures la question c'est est ce
qu'il ya des marques qui sont su kyi qui
pensent que elle leur apporte
suffisamment de notoriété pour payer ces
personnes autant visiblement oui alors
effectivement peut-être que ça va
s'effondrer et d'ailleurs elles sont pas
elles sont pas si stupide que ça puisque
la plupart d'entre elles et d'entre eux
ont commencé à monter des marques
elle-même c'est-à-dire pour devenir leur
propre marque après notamment la villa
qui fait du cosmétique etc et donc c'est
voilà
gilles verdez n'est pas choqué si je
suis étonné par toi non parce que
effectivement
c'est
selon si jamais vraiment c'est comme les
joueurs de foot pour moi la mérite c'est
ça évidemment que c'est choquant pour
les gens qui aiment le stick je le
conçois bien volontiers mais ce sont les
les huit premiers là les huit premières
elles ont créé des entreprises qui en
plus ont du succès elle emploie des gens
alors c'est c'est pas vrai que hugo
c'est pas vrai c'est pas vrai que tout
est à dubaï non j'ai dit l'exercice oui
mais oui majorité qu'elle examine s'il
n'y a plus de la moitié est imposée
s'est imposée en france quand l'activité
en france est tombée par exemple je
prends l'exemple de jazz et laurent jazz
à la été rayés des de snapshot pendant
un long moment oui oui oui jazz elle a
été rayé de snapshot pendant un long
moment mais bien elle a été privée de
revenus donc c'est fragile aussi c'est
éphémère qui sait très bien que lors de
vos quatre cent mille euros par mois ça
va mais c'est comme les jours et vous tu
peux être privés de revenus pendant ce
temps mais gilles verdez jeu-là d'or
mais je ne comprends pas c'est un croisé
avec l'obliqué comme moi et comprend pas
il nous sort quand même qu'à une meuf
qui gagne 250 mille euros par mois et
non attention pendant deux mois l'été
privés de revenus mais je crois que tata
technologies ouais mais tu es tombé sur
la tête raymond dans les salaires
indécents moi d'abord je suis pas jaloux
et tant mieux et profite d'un système
qui fonctionne surtout la turque
lapandry fait profil bas et profite d'un
système qui fonctionne ils sont à dubaï
il gagne de l'argent il défiscalisent là
où j'ai tu te trompes tu dis c'est comme
les genres de foot c'est pas comme un
joueur de foot parce qu'un joueur de
foot moi pourquoi j'ai toujours dit que
ça me dérangeait pas les 800 milles 1
million d'euros par mois parce que sur
les 1 million 600 mille qui restent en
france parce que tu peux pas dire il est
parti à dubaï on l'avait joué à rennes
on l'a vu jouer à nice on a besoin de
jouer à l'écran
ses premières qui jouent à l'étranger
c'est pas ça devoir suivre la carrière
du beach tennis made you this event
l'argent dans le monde entier raisin un
footballeur enfance il reste dans la
logique d'un super and sciences il est
l'homme deuxième truc qui me dérange
c'est vie c'est un travail il a
travaillé 3 à 4
[Applaudissements]
il a travaillé
j'adore j'adore il ya trois-quatre
heures tant mieux pour eux point que ça
me dérange c'est qu'ils vendent des
produits parfois qu'ils sont un peu un
pitot était un peu un peu à rien de
malhonnête et un peu un peu dangereux
je suis content pour eux sur les
émergents du jardin il toucha millions
d'euros dont 1 million d'euros par film
ils travaillent quatre mois les gens du
combat mais
non
c'est une énorme star c'est un énorme
talent sera content parce que c'est un
jean dujardin y gagnent beaucoup moins
que oui parce que c'est beaucoup mais
combien d'enseignants mathieu camaïeu
mais tu que michaëlle jean dujardin à
l'industrie du cinéma est donc y aller
doucement combien d'emplois près la
situation
nombre
[Applaudissements]
alors
c'est vrai
alors que ce qu on a retrouvé ma
boutique en ligne on retrouve sa
boutique dans la re pourquoi en ligne
parce que tu vas défiscalisant mairie
pour si c'est si facile je dois le faire
moi j'ai pas le talent j'ai pas les
moyens je crois qu'il
ya combien de la via del maggio et
maggio lionel mathieu emporté
comparaison en ce moment tu es pergolèse
non personne ne sait si je te dis tous
le disent sur les réseaux c'est quand
même jean dujardin saavedra dernier mais
non mais tout se dire que vous arrivez
toujours un nom je n'ai mais j'en eus
jamin il est rare negreanu mort non mais
désormais joly ou
jean dujardin pour aride où il en est il
se rend compte les heures de travail
qu'a fait jean dujardin ville elle
arrivée là comment non mais mais non
mais compare pas à tort nabila et tout
c'est que j'adore nabila j'adore mes
bras ils profitent pas de la naïveté de
son plan mais c'est pas la naïveté mais
non mais comme il le disait justement
les gens qui accordent à ce que vivront
la bulle il utilise les gens qui les
sièges fo cité des ducs ou ici les
aérosols puis elle prend pas les gens
pour des cons à bil'in avec mépris non
les produits qu'elle vend en effet du
drop shipping ses pinceaux mais les
autres le regardent a demandé leur qui a
été arnaquée par le drop shipping
remplir
une influence euzenat qui dit regarder
comment ça lui prend son travail astrid
regardez à super non mais je peux même
te demander si tu arrives à bien gagner
avec ce réseau social parce que c'est
nouveau donc je ne cache pas que je
curieux si je peux te dire une
fourchette je peux gagner entre 20 à 100
mille euros et ça te prend combien de
temps dans la semaine créer les photos
et les postes aux messages privés c'est
du temps minutes par jour trois minutes
par jour bah ouais trop trois minutes
par jour pour récolter entre
300000 euros elles gagnent à johnny fans
mais j'ai un pote à moi c'est un très
grand footballeur n'a inscrit appelle
moi je vais leur dire moi comment ça
fonctionne le football c'est des malades
non mais ça n'a rien à voir donc tu vois
ça n'a rien à voir ce que digérer ça n'a
rien à voir c'est papa la c1 à voir
surgir deux formations depuis qu'ils ont
13 ans ils bossent comme des malades
l'un d'eux me ripert important d'en voir
plus que dit géraldine est ce que je
disais tout à l'heure c'est que quand
ils vont à l'étranger et coutumes en
espagne en angleterre c'est pas pour les
vrais pas pour des questions fiscales
pour la carrière notamment chester city
qui t'appelle tu as envie d'y aller
quand tu as le real qui t'appelle tu
envie d'y aller débattre bêtise décès ça
n'a rien à voir un fou dans ce que vous
dites c'est que peu importe formation
quoi gagner de l'argent à ce niveau là
c'est une forme de talent mais bien sûr
avec deux heures trente cinq heures pour
une habile à l'école
de foot et quand même ma mère de
l'argent honnêtement oui bah oui
qu'est-ce que tu vas
manger qu'un système de ponzi qui est un
peu bizarre où il ya beaucoup de gens
les dix premiers qui vont être payés
mais voilà et puis les ceux qui sont
derrière là ils sont jamais payées et ça
permet de payer beaucoup ceux qui sont
en haut et je dis que tout ça est très
opaque voilà c'est fini je vais avoir
tout un village soit et c'est non non
non moi je suis pas choqué par les
montants parce que s'ils font rapporter
de l'argent aux marques n'y a pas de
problème le seul souci effectivement
c'est cette histoire d'impôts parce
qu'il ya dans les influenceurs des
influenceurs français qui gagnent juste
un peu moins qui sont pas dans vos
tableaux et au final payent des impôts
beaucoup
par exemple toi tu fais des placements
de produits tu peux aider un peu oui
tout est là tu es ce que tu as une boîte
à l'étranger pour des pannes est-ce que
tu as maintenant moi c'est un autre
exemple c'est quand exemple mais juste
mais juste en dessous de pas pouvoir
aller à dubaï ou de ne pas y aller bien
c'est là qu'on se fait toujours à voir
quoi et c'est dommage ça c'est vrai faut
pas être jaloux ses travers 350 milles
moi je les prends vous êtes bien sûr
mais dites moi que ce soit jean dujardin
des footballeurs qui mérite de gagner
moi je vais être oui très démago et tout
ça mais je me dis que je vais dire ce
que tout le monde pense tout bas c'est
sait combien ces vingt ans de smig on a
en a moins qui mérite ça mais dites-moi
qui mérite ça mais jacqueline démagogie
voit la bce ni
parce qu'ils demeurent pas c'est tout le
monde est là personne n'a envie de voir
ça tu mérite pas je
me disais qu'en fait il qu'ils gagnent
et je pense que le dernier mot et ils
pensent les juges en ont rêvé qui
partait le matin et ça fait c'était
peut-être démago mais si ils avaient
presque honte de gagner autant d'argent
et pas mais mai dernier sur la péninsule
et relève
le montant de tu prends là pour 3h tpm
police et
110 et branchements quand même
[Applaudissements]
mais si j'avais 20 ans et que je pourrai
gagner ça peut-être que je le ferai je
partira sans doute pas du bac moi c'est
la société qui permet ça qu'ils m'ont
j'ai envie de voter mélenchon au dessus
d'une certaine somme on prend tout je
suis désolé personne ne mérite ça là là
là où la mer et non mais je
pense qu'il ya plein de gens et plein de
personnes qui pensent mais je vais y
aller c'est vrai que mathieu ce qui vous
a dit aussi dans ce cas là vous vous
êtes dans la tranche au triplé audi
vient firme hier je suis bien payé tu
fais ce qu'elle a dit comme le smic et
moi je suis jouer je le dis moi souvent
j'ai ici je défends aussi comme tu dis
mais faut pas il ya des gens qui créent
beaucoup beaucoup d'emplois comme cyril
qui fait des 220 oui en fait il ya des
grosses huiles vuitton carrefour auchan
qui font démocratiquement avec mention
tortue ce sont des chefs dansions
français
de smic tu devrais garder toi pour ta
ligne est au smic 60 euros nets dans ta
poche tout le reste que tu touches tu
dois te donne rdv la nasa des
dérangements
vous qu'est ce que vous en pensez mais
évidemment mais évidemment c'est
indécent mais d'abord premièrement s'il
ya des gens pour qu'ils ordonnent
pourquoi ne pas le prendre et moi
surtout bresse qui me plaisent bourse id
systems mois pour ces gens là qui ont et
dont on a abusé nous autres producteurs
et de chaînes télé il ya vingt ans les
camps d'été l'arrêter ou pas fait du
tout d'oseille et je trouve que c'est
très bien qu'aujourd'hui le scud se soit
renversé que et que aujourd'hui ils
prennent le pouvoir et qu'ils prennent
un peu d'eau dépasse question pendant
des années on les a utilisés ils en
payent de retour sur leur investissement
et aujourd'hui voilà c'est très bien
aimé en france il est évident que lorena
par exemple est
absolument est ce que il ya des gens qui
disent également que les footballeurs
créé énormément d'emplois il s'appelait
une norme les manettes c'est un énorme
voilà rien su parce qu'on les a comparés
à des footballeurs et elle est en
finissent mieux et qu'elle emploie il
crée donc c'est ça aussi qui pose un peu
problème sur les salaires mais après
est-ce qu' ils ont volé personne non
mais est-ce que après ce que on se dit
est ce que si vous voulez proposer vous
raymond vous referiez non moi je moi je
refuserai pas
on veut on vole personne c'est juste
après une déontologie par rapport aux
produits que tu vas t'amuser avant tu me
propose d'aller faire des trucs je doute
bien qu'on me propose d'aller faire des
trucs à 2000 euros pour 2h va la feci
3000 euros mais moi un poste ingrat
24000 euros le fait pas et quand je le
fais pas je réponds aux mecs je pleure
en pleurant vu dit non parce que j'ai
pas envie d'être un produit j'ai pas
envie de vendre un truc que je sais pas
j'ai pas envie de vendre un parfum que
je connais pas cette le dernier dès
qu'on n'en est qu'à moi je suis là je
reste ici je prends l'argent ici
franchement avoir ni bravo bien mais
c'est pas bravo c'est juste une question
de mentalité si eux ils sont jeunes et
qu'ils ont envie d'être il il ne vole
pas l'argent je le dis bien il vole pas
je dis juste faut pas comparer les
footballeurs faut pas comparer avec jean
dujardin qui eux sont de l'activité ici
voilà c'est qui est de la france parce
que noah à côté de ça on peut se soigner
on peut aller à l'école et que c'est par
accepter la ville a par exemple on est
on adore la vie note adam laloum bien
accoucher
pourquoi la couche en france cette voie
c'est des trucs comme ça mais c'est plus
sûr
je ne suis pas
je suis important forcément il a dit des
choses un peu c'est de la censure de
produits qu'ils vendent ça ce sont des
sons qui sont pas de la merde et qui
sont réellement des produits dont ils
ont vérifié qu'ils n'étaient pas tous
les sahraouis mais ça c'est un autre
débat ça
pour moi c'est pas de rester en france
mais ça c'était celle ci mais accroît
votre question pour vous et donnerait ce
que voulait prendriez on leur donne pas
ils sont dix parmi huit mille et ils ont
réussi à bien ces a gagné un business
lui et moi c'est toujours pardon
admirative des gens qui se bougent le
cul qui se lève et qui ont gagné de
l'argent visite bas par rapport au pic
de la décision
qui nous donne des 100 sur le smic bape
arnaut-daniel mais depuis le temps
theresa may de morini bosc et élevée aux
voyants elles ont quand même une autre
gueule quand même parce que tu es là
tous les soirs tu prends un très bon
salaire tous les soirs et pardon mais tu
gagnes très très bons amis isabelle et
l'aris appel qui sera dans tpm people
n'ont absolument qu il appelle tous les
bars venir dans les cuisines j'attends
qu'ils nous avaient les crocs stationné
l'argent de l'argent tu le dis en
revanche argenteuil donne parce que
c'est beaucoup moins dur d'être
chroniqueuse dans tpm paix comme tu le
fais tous les soirs que d'aller créer un
système pour gagner de l'argent avec une
marque et tout ça sur glace a cédé 10
ans ne devrait pas y avoir c'est ça la
question c'est quoi la question je
m'engage je n'en veux absolument pas
c'est indécent et j'aurai vingt ans
aujourd'hui et au public c'est indécent
c'est indécent des gens descendent
parfois mcdaniels je réponds à une
question à la raison alors que c'est
indécent il est bien pour beaucoup de
gens que son salaire est indécent daniel
ménard s'est plusieurs fois estimé qu'il
est indécent bon trois heures de boulot
par jour mais bien sûr et quand je vois
des infirmières et toucha bien sûr que
je me dis que c'est pas normal et en
plus on nous on nous dit des
gentillesses dans la rue tu crois que
c'est normal est-ce que les infirmières
qui sont ils ont travaillé toute la nuit
mais c'est un matériau non plus on
favorise bien mais moi on aime ce serait
bien mais
nous ont très bien payé
en
tout cas moi je pense que voilà va
s'arrêter quand est
ce qu'ils les 24
oui oui les 23 janvier à tarnac et oui
parce que ça nécessite une voiture de ce
côté là un peu le côté a plus on est
assis on donne des leçons mais moi je
réponds à cette question on a 10 kg j'ai
pas facile de s'attaquer à ces instar de
la tl était parce que vous me re toqués
sur le football je prends d'autres
secteurs il ya des chefs d'entreprise ya
des chefs d'entreprise prennent de
grandes entreprises qui vont en belgique
etc il ya des acteurs qui vont à
l'étranger vous vous payez tous vos
impôts en france pour quelqu'un comme
vous qui payent tous vos impôts en
france dans le monde de la télé il y en
a qui s'exhibe etc c'est par d'autres
n'y a pas il n'y a pas que dans
l'attaqué scaramanga si la zone franc
suisse
l'un des ferments
ya pas que dans la ville alors il faut
leur tomber dessus mais il n'ya pas que
y'a pas que tu es là je trouve ça un peu
facile parce que dubaï c'est un symbole
sans doute que ces patenaude dubaï mais
y en a qui sont ensuite à monaco cyril
j'en connais des dizaines à monaco voilà
donc on paye pas d'impôts il faut là moi
je trouve que c'est facile voilà une
frappe ratée ragots j allais fassi tu
vas pas croire que tu t'es pas au
courant qu'un chef d'entreprise qui
crèche du travail c'est qu'il ya en
belgique bien sûr qui la rend bézian
crémant paraître et en belgique avant ça
tombe bien il paye d'impôts sur l'aven
donc voila tu sais la volonté des chefs
d'entreprise savourer ça vous
voulez parler l'art dé 100 anciens chefs
d'entreprise se bat tous les jours pour
sa société pour créer 200 emplois pour
nourrir deux cents familles se lève à 6h
du matin pour arriver dans sa société
c'est moins indécent que quelqu'un qui
va se lever à 11h en se grattant sous
l'épaule écoulée l'eau
m
c'est indécent raymond voyage en moyenne
avant les boîtes du cac pèse 7 %
d'impôts mais je suis revenu cette
saison tu le sais ça on s'en doute mais
ça veut dire quoi que les très très
riches paient pas que ces mamans pascal
rain man autorisé mais le truc alors je
suis d'accord justement connais pas va
bien sûr est il en train de faire
inverser le truc pour défendre n'est pas
qu'on sera salée c'est marrant cette
excuse est l'habitant luce et ses gosses
qui fait non je défends encore une fois
peu importe je dis que là où je rejoins
gill s'est arrêté de vous en priver
rejoignez le dubaï mais on s'en vend pas
la peau
des dérives de ces machins livre l
étranger je trouve est tombé sur cela
hier des gens qui gagnent de l'argent
ont-ils rappelé roland garros pendant
quinze jours c'est combien tva pour la
france et ça c'est un échec
[Applaudissements]
quelqu'un qui gagnent de l'argent mais
qui n'emploie personne c'est une merde
non quinquas qui gagnent de l'argent qui
n'emploie personne par son téléphone qui
prend 350 peut nous leur affaire en
vendant des produits blizzard ad
français ou les loulous
[Applaudissements]
grâce au français nexans et ne vont pas
payer je vais te dire moi c'est comme si
en revanche moi et moi et moi je suis
enregistré des missions donc deux jours
par semaine et que le reste du temps
j'habitais en suisse voilà non voilà
nous n'allons pas plus loin c'est comme
si tu mettais ton entreprise en belgique
au luxembourg aux îles caïmans et qu'on
recevait un virement la batteuse et
c'est comme ceux recevant virement de
chine ça va nous aider
demain va être fait pas je choisis
cocoon
je résume calment
salut ou choisi le calme alors on est
bien j'espère que vous allez bien sûr
cela moi je vais faire du kitesurf est à
13 heures voilà donc j'ai ça si vous
aviez bien tout à l'heure mais lui
décernant même et tu fais ça pendant
quatre heures m es tu fais des montages
financiers dessous oui c'est essayer de
vous rappelez vous de me le garde avait
devant lui un poste avec votre nom donné
à une menace et cyril sur son sur ses
followers qu'il avait eue je crois 20000
euros je crois fin des 5 minutes 25 mai
oui c'est donc c'est énorme et cyril
hanouna c'est une référence je peux
comprendre aussi que fait-on quand tu
fais la caricature il ya des il ya des
ja dévia dévalorisation de l'image ne
sont pas les mêmes allez qui va me sucer
disponibles
le sondage quand même voir le sondage
bva être facile de son âge mais
évidemment à 8% alors je croyais pas que
c'est
qu'ils accord avec des liens avec
raymond mais
j'ai pas que tant mieux pour eux
s'ils mettent de côté ou qui mettent de
côté parce que pour l'instant il profite
d'un système qui met de côté je veux pas
les voir dans cinq ans ici ou à la télé
que vous allez dire queen et
tant pis pour toi je profite et kiki
mode ya des entreprises qui monte des
entreprises qu'ils fassent des choses
assez bien creux et sans parce que
j'aime mon avis nour explique ta théorie
ce
matin j'y vis j'y aurais quand tu
démissionnes
quoi tu davis quand tu utilises pas
quand tu débutes chedeville
saint-arthémy super tout aimé e ils ont
publié beaucoup plus d'argent que j'en
ai gagné dans ma vie évidemment
ça va pas du tout
cinquante mille euros par mois jamais
jamais même après quatre mois et demi
d'euros par an benjamin fall a ou des
factures facture sans voiture de société
donc la société d'accord après ce revers
il reste reste quand même un petit truc
mais si
l'un d'eux se faisait escroqué sur un
énorme affaire immobilière je sais pas
laquelle et qui mettaient tout leur
pognon dedans et qu'il n'avait plus rien
il pourrait aussi des visites rêvait
toujours mais j'ai toujours fait la
différence on en a parlé on en a parlé
ensemble j'ai toujours fait la
différence entre quelqu'un qui se fait
escroquer ce roquet et quinta flamber
voilà un quart car flambé j'ai aucune
pitié pour lui activement
pour ce mec là mais quelqu'un qui s'est
fait voler son argent mais les filets
celui-là c'est pas de sa faute
d escorte à 750 la
cdpa mont lozère processus qui va du
casino bas que tu as gagné je comprends
mieux je comprends mieux maintenant en
fait en fait c'est ça bah oui parce que
même quand tf1 le pays
mais c'est quand on te paye en fête ses
21 salaires en fait après ça devient ton
argent à
dépenser de l'argent comme a donné tf1
comprend après quand j'en aurai pluies
vont ordonner c'est comme ça c'est comme
ça mais l'argent du jeu il pu voir ces
personnes qui payent pas d'impôts en
france moi quand ils viennent en france
pour se faire soigner j'aimerais bien
qu'ils payent leurs soins ah oui ça par
contre avec ce serait si ça ce n'est pas
parce que pour renault pour tous ces
mouvements de voir les biens sont tous
ceux qui s'en vont enfin % voire dans
d'autres pays et qui viennent chanter
ici qui vient d'ardèche mauvaise foi
j'entends juste c'est que on tape sur
ces gens et à raison qu'ils partent à
dubaï c'est très mal mais confirme tous
nos gars c'est d'accord avec gilles sur
beaucoup de noms qu'on connaît ce que
j'avais à dire ce footballeur à
l'étranger et des petits riens et on
n'ose pas citer les nourrissant monaco
des chanteurs des acteurs et des gens
c'est pas aussi des blancs des beurs
c'est plus facile de taper sur retour
des grands lacs en ciel accord moi je
moi je tape pas moi j'aime bien cette
équipe n'est pas de moi j'ai conçu ce
qui énerve
vous avez toujours dit si comme laurent
wauquiez d'ailleurs vous étiez très fier
de payer beaucoup d'impôts ouais ouais
ça ça me viendrait pas à l'idée de merde
alors le montage financier dont a parlé
rémy
l'abominable quand même passé un coup de
fil à mon conseiller
gens tombent sur ce sujet you genton de
langue sur ce sujet il arrêtait là d'un
côté là